1982 logos that load on an early Apple
computer screen Jesus Vangelis obviously
wasn't happy with just a music by
crediting these opening credits are so
long even the soundtrack isn't really
sure when it's supposed to come in
techno reading movie betrays its
character bias in the opening text
scroll 2019 damn you want must better
step up his game if we're gonna complete
this timeline it takes over three
minutes for this movie to begin Blade
Runner II
I'm sure the movie has some flimsy
reason but seeing gas fire plug out at
the tops of buildings in the LA skyline
just seems stupidest actually what they
turn buildings into gas pipelines
seriously the pacing of this movie makes
Gone with the Wind look like a Rick and
Morty episode you're in a desert walking
along and then all of a sudden you learn
what desert Leone would be excellent at
cinemasins
tell you about my mother I know Leon's a
superhuman replica and all but he lands
a perfect kill shot with this pistol
while underneath the table and it has
enough force behind it to throw Holden
through the fucking wall also they
didn't screen for a gun when the
possible replicant went through this
extremely emotional testing also I guess
Leon just quietly escaped after this
incident even though this killing of a
police officer was in the midst of a
heavily guarded corporate headquarters
during business hours movie thought Pan
Am would still be a thing in 2019 what's
next a flashing billboard for Tower
Records or a new brendan fraiser film a
futuristic society with flying cars
sentient AI and light-up umbrellas still
also uses physical newspapers a new life
awaits you
an ounce position as an observation
angle gonna be thick mr. Decker the
restaurant dude was unable to speak
English for Deckard a few seconds ago
but is immediately called upon to
translate for the cops also how the fuck
did the old man hear what the cop said
from all the way over there took me
several listens to realize he's using
this city speak stuff the award for
worst sound editing ever goes to Fame
Blade Runner movie unintentionally
inspires uninspired future violence porn
film franchise yes this is 1982 and yes
that is a Cuisinart product placement
you just didn't realize how early the
problem began is all movie is proof that
if you future porn enough people will
overlook a convoluted story and consider
you a classic I need you death ah the
old retired dick comes out of retirement
for one last adventure cliche might not
have been so bad back in the 80s but
still nothing original I need the old
Blade Runner roll credits there was an
escape from the offworld colonies two
weeks ago six replicants three males
free female but I neglected to tell you
these details until after we started
watching the footage of the voight-komp
test three nights ago they tried to
break in the Tyrell corporation on the
possibility they might try to infiltrate
his employees I had hold and go over and
run voight-komp
tests and the new workers hang on how
could they be set up as hired employees
less than three days after they broke
into the headquarters this is one of the
biggest corporations in the world right
do they not have an HR department what
do they want out of the Tyrell
corporation oh you tell me pal that's
what you're here for something literally
on fire between these two because
neither one of them has been smoking
during the scene they were designed the
coffee human beings in every way kept
their emotions okay I guess we need this
obvious exposition how does Deckard not
already know this he's been a Blade
Runner for long enough to develop a
notable track record he's never run into
a nexus 6 model or heard how they were
made okay obviously coca-cola is still
gonna be around in 2019 but this future
assumes they're still gonna be using the
same slogan as the one in 1982 the movie
only seems long because it keeps
spending time on scenes like this
suggest something is going to happen
during the space journey when in reality
the only thing that occurs is that you
watch said space journey for 60 seconds
replicants are like any other machine
that's repla system and I want to see a
negative before I provide you with a
positive what's that gonna prove
indulge me and so he does because
reasons as the digital shades go down
and this room gets dark even while it's
a beautiful shot still
inside this Alan's burning and you've
got to be thinking oh it's hot in time
do you mind if I smoke it won't affect
the test sure those enormous plumes of
smoke that are obscuring the shots of
your eyes that were specifically
monitoring will have no effect on this
test whatsoever she's a replicant isn't
she well I thought the test II was
administering was able to tell that 100%
Deckard later learns that she's an
advanced replicant and the test is now
in question but still he seems pretty
casual about his uncertainty here like
god dude confirms his suspicions
immediately more human than human is our
motto
Looby accidentally inspires terrible
repetitive white zombie song rachel is
an experiment nothing more a completely
illegal experiment that I'm opening
disclosing to an actual police officer
I'm so rich are you gonna do about it
look if this one building is willing to
digitally whore itself for ad dollars in
this future
why would none of the surrounding
buildings be lit up with product
placement as well okay I guess in the
future cops just touch evidence
willy-nilly all so what is it with
Ridley Scott and movies where characters
stupidly touch an unknown foreign
substance Deckard first put his finger
into this green goo in the tub before
picking up the scale but his fingers
completely clean here cool origami gaff
but were you planning on helping out in
this investigation at all someone was
there men man I don't want to piss off
all those Rutger Hauer fans out there
but this performance is so overacted
then I think it inspired the last 20
years of Al Pacino's career highly the
Angels why would a replicant good or
evil be prone to speaking in poetry
I don't know ANSYS who does time god
damn it once again how does Roy not know
this information
they've already infiltrated Tyrells
headquarters but they don't know the guy
in charge it's the guy with the fucking
answers where would we find this
GEB best god damn even the dialogue in
this movie takes forever even in the
midst of this monsoon Deckard refuses to
use the windshield wiper and even if the
cars self-driving what's the point of a
windshield wiper at all especially one
that's hilariously tiny relative to this
enormous windshield
what is this fashion statement a half
hood an overgrown collar does she hate
peripheral vision or what he wouldn't
see me
I guess Deckard is able to suspend his
hatred of replicants after meeting
Rachel because the power of boners is
greater than the power of duty thank God
this one light in the bar came on
otherwise this entire room would still
be bathed in darkness and shet oh I'm
sorry
honestly the words stare at each other
for a while turn up together in that
order 15 times in this movie script
motion sensing lights futuristic mr.
coffee coffee maker decided the late
1900s for some reason she leaves
abruptly he sees it and he doesn't say
anything or following because all the
characters in this movie know there's a
mystery involved that doesn't want it to
Pitts and too soon by characters doing
logical things didn't the six replicants
that escaped kill a bunch of people in
the shuttle aren't they super wanted by
the police right now
I mean Brian showed their mug shots to
Decker so they must have distributed
them to the regular police why is pris
walking around in front of all these
cops right now
got a great acting job and all but pris
is a beautiful pleasure bot he's all the
subterfuge to get Sebastian really
necessary when she could essentially
just offer him like Pablo job I mean he
might not look like it but this is a
red-blooded 25 year old we scared each
other pretty good didn't we
I sure did we should be friends because
of that they're toys my friends totally
nothing Sebastian is Sid from Toy Story
all grown up she's pretty but how the
hell does a guy with this many locks on
his door fall for this why are there no
lights on in this ginormous apartment I
know release count wanted to create a
dark brooding universe this place should
have a ton of electricity
considering dude animates nightmares
here in his spare time do Androids Dream
of Electric unicorns running through the
woods and here you go the inclusion of
this fucking unicorn dream scene is
central to the debate over whether
Deckard is a replicant or not since gaff
will later do a unicorn origami thing
but why the fuck is it a unicorn at all
and is it Deckard's only dream he's ever
had my point is this is a weird-ass
image to use as the crux of the argument
that Deckard is not human it could've
had a dream about fucking Rachel which
would be a lot more enjoyable and would
be awesome to see gaff turned that into
origami and has 224 176 zoom and enhance
cliche who in the future decided we
wanted or needed light fixtures in our
couches right behind where our heads
want the naturally rest boobie is so in
love with its voice-activated video
technology have forgot to have Dekker
tell it what it was to Center on there
are a handful of things in the shot when
he says center and pull back and yet
somehow the software reads his mind it
shows him exactly what he wants to see
it was actually more amazing than
replicant building technology remember
this is all in the background mirror of
the original shop fYI if Deckard is able
to get this absurd level of detail in
this photograph the technology would not
operate like a
projector your hardcopy right there not
really about the movie but this reminds
me of my wife's grandmother who every
time we took a photo with our phones
would tell one of us send me a paper
picture of that also only in movies
particularly sci-fi movies can a care to
go from blindingly drunk to astute and
sober as a judge within seconds this
picture in no way resembles the image or
angle he was looking at when he asked
for a hard copy
[Music]
I know I made a crack about Vangelis
earlier but the music in this movie is
so amazingly unique and influential damn
it I gotta remove a sin this is some
kind of restaurant but they serve both
shark and bloap holy Sh that guy has an
eagle on his head fish I think it was
manufactured look man it sure is
convenient that Deckard has a molecular
analyst seafood vendor nearby to his
house and what kind of person says I'm
gonna start a fish stand and maybe we'll
sell fish but our first and most
important commodity will be the ability
to determine if small flesh samples are
indeed from fish
he made this me oh and he's just right
over there right fantastic luck this is
a future where street vendors can
analyze flesh samples and tell you if
their fish or not but also still has
randos hurting ostriches through the
alleys it's super advanced and super
dilapidated all at the same time
Jesus Deckard let him take a look at it
first if he's the artificial snake
salesman this movie has made him out to
be he probably sold tons of them and
can't ID a single buyer from a single
slice of fake snake flesh on site
Louisa's down imperfecta chinatown holy
Sh he did identify the buyer within
three seconds of looking at the sample
man Deckard isn't so much a great
detective as he is lucky as fuck two
things I like about this future that
super unnecessary long pipes are back in
fashion and that bartenders are allowed
to smoke said super unnecessarily long
pipes while on the job power to the
people
so Deckard knows or is pretty sure this
chick is a replicant but he's still
booty calls her from a bar so either
Deckard is down with replicant sir just
loves King more than he loves drinking
I'm from the American Federation of
variety artists this is kind of
hilarious but why Deckard need to use a
different voice
Zor has no clue who he is I'd like to
check your dressing room
for holes well you'd be surprised when a
guy go through to get a glimpse of a
beautiful body dude she just performed
naked with a snake for the last several
minutes everyone got a glimpse of her
body weight she just showers that oh
it's gotta take her like hours to get
all bedazzled right there's got to be a
more efficient method of all the things
the future people waste money on this is
somehow one of them how much you want to
bet some startup trust fund idiot sees
the upcoming sequel to this movie then
watch as the original sees this at home
hair drying bubble thing and starts a
new company around making these things a
real product I'll go 200 bucks on my own
not real
you gotta be working in a place like
this if I could afford a real snake I
don't know it seemed to be living in
relative luxury how much could a real
snake possibly cost like half of what
the walk-in shower and personal salon
air drying apparatus cost yeah just let
me slip into something a little more
comfortable this is why no one should
ever be forced to wear a necktie you
just never know when a replicant
stripper is going to suddenly try and
choke you out bullsh
Zhora was just running at a full sprint
down an empty road and Deckard's been
stumbling around in the midst of all
this foot traffic but of course he
somehow catches up to work boy Deckard
sure got his killin boner up tonight
didn't he I mean he knows Rachel's a
replicant but didn't kill her because
she was hot
and now he's got Zoar in his sights
who's also hot but I guess Deckard
prefers no way out to Who Framed Roger
Rabbit
did someone get the cinematographer the
day off when they shot this and didn't
tell Ridley Scott after seeing this
replicant get shot and get back up I'd
really like to know what they can and
can't do I thought the movie is never
interested in telling us Jesus how many
panes of glass are there in this fucking
store movie just goes way too far
overboard trying to let me know that
Deckard likes to drink I'm almost drunk
just from the multiple dexhart as a
drunk shots
I mean subtlety is a word for a reason
I'm getting distracted from the plot by
all these fucking pedestrians walking
literally between Street lanes death
wish anyone nothing is worse than having
an itch you can never scratch
I guess replicants also enjoy pithy
one-liners between beatings to the
protagonist
[Music]
yes even the beloved Blade Runner has ex
machina moments deal with it look I know
la is a pretty rough city these days but
no one in this crowd of looking Street
at least notices the killing of some
dude they you don't know he's a
replicant not even leaving Las Vegas
tried this hard to convince you its main
character like the sauce I am the
business Dan's like the only directions
Ridley Scott gave a Shawn young were to
smoke cry and we're enormous fur coats
come on man she played like two measures
while you were passed out on the couch
this is such an obvious come on that
even a replicant should be able to sniff
it out he already knows think she's a
replicant but apparently is just horny
enough not to care
either that or replicant technology is
advanced to the point where they can
have real emotional attachments with
humans I don't care which is which I'm
just sitting it because the movie
basically explains nothing I'm kind of
disgruntled about it it sure feels like
this movie forgot how to Daryl its
Hannah hi Roy
earlier we saw the sebastian using this
absurdly secure locking system and we
don't see pris unlocking it so Roy get
in here what generation are you Nexus 6
I thought Roy didn't even know who had
the answers at Tyrell corporation does
he know what generation II is that
priests we also can't allow a consistent
accent on poor old Rutger Hauer
meanwhile at the Jedi Temple maybe cool
the tyrell has an Amazon echo in a movie
from 1982 but it takes place in 2019 by
which time Alexa will definitely be all
news what can he do for you and then
make every pound he may would you like
to be modified is every line in this
conversation gonna be a question so what
if it is does anyone want to make a
declarative statement does it matter
will this movie ever just get to the
point that seems to be the problem
well for starters all the goddamn
candles in this room I'm one more knife
father movie uses the glowy eyes trick
whenever it wants the replicants to look
like replicates but this is the first
time we've seen Roy's eyes do this so if
it's a matter of the light hitting the
irises in a certain way why doesn't
Deckard use various positions with a
flashlight
instead of that bulky ass voight-komp
machine wait Rutger Hauer here just
killed the head of this ginormous
fucking company and he just bounces
there's no security or code or pass or
something to keep him in the building
for no reason at all Ridley Scott wanted
to feature his version of Jawas in this
scene one of the reasons this movie is
as long as it is is because it lets
really stupid Beaumont's like Deckard
entering the building and climbing the
stairs play out in virtually real-time
geez why people think Deckard is a
replicant if this chick kicks his ass so
handily and he has to shoot her with a
gun to win the battle also Bruce is a
sex robot specifically designed for
leisure how'd she get these fight
upgrades that are effective against a
well seasoned Blade Runner
this goes on for some time
come on me how does Roy know his name
god dammit characters just know and
don't know things willy nilly in this
movie cool a shot bro but how the did he
know exactly where to punch through that
wall
so his Deckard trying to escape because
he could have just left the way he came
in
considering he's gotten a tremendous
head start Rory strips down to his
skivvies for the final cheese sequence
because this movie hasn't been visually
creepy enough already yep the artificial
humanoid thing is piercing his own hands
with nails Allah Christ because well I
don't know you want to live but he's
gonna die he's a robot
somehow he's decided a christ analogy is
deserved and honestly if it gets us
closer to the end of this movie so be it
I'm gonna kill ya after being a literal
superhuman the entirety of this movie
really turns into a horror movie villain
cliche for the last several minutes I
mean is there any reason for him to toy
with Deckard at this point besides for
the audience somehow Deckard finds
himself temporarily in Dark City time to
die wait but it's 2019 right Roy's in
septate was 2016 and the Nexus 6
generation has a 4 year lifespan so what
the fuck happened here the slow mode of
shot is basically a prophecy of Zack
Snyder and John woos careers
I guess you're through huh and I guess
you pimp version of edward james olmos
have conveniently waited until the end
of the movie to speak english so
obviously only the new generation of
replicants can experience emotions if
Deckard's are replicant then he's in the
same generation as Rachel and he's only
been around for a few years max and if
that's the case then everyone's in on
the plan including Bryant gaff Tyrell
Holden and the entire LA Police
Department and that's some bullshit
replicants are the future but I can only
like so many
[Music]
more human than human is our motto I'm
Larry this is my brother Daryl that's my
other brother Daryl snakes why did it
have to be snakes so that I may talk
squirrel here's Johnny
ever dance with the devil in the pale
why
[Music]
Harvey use the Force
gentlemen we can rebuild him we have the
technology